I gotta ask you also about the Gilmore  Girls reboot wrapping up how'd you feel  about the way things wrapped up um you  know I think there was still a lot of  questions up in the air with Jess he it  looks like there's still some feelings  he's feeling for Rory's so you know it's  funny I I never really thought too much  about what was happening beyond when I  left the show so for for jest to be  still wondering you know uh fascinating  another reboot would you would you jump  right you know what if Dan and Amy  called me of course i'd be happy to be  there yeah a lot of fans would be very  happy to hear that yeah who'd you bring  is your date tonight me myself and I and  my lovely cast we have a great gray cast  you got a good turn we did yeah yeah  yeah as you well sure this is a well on  a lot of people's minds so good luck  tonight  you  you